this video is brought to you by
brilliant knock something off your
holiday to-do list right now
give someone the gift of learning with
brilliant just go to brilliant.org
forward slash biographics and gift a
premium subscription
scientists are exactly the most
well-known people in the world and
yet there are a few names among them
which have established themselves
firmly in the public's consciousness
alexander fleming
is one of those names inexorably linked
with the discovery of penicillin
even people who have never studied
science or medicine
in their lives may have still heard the
story of how fleming's messiness
accidentally yielded the first
antibiotic in the world
they've heard how he left behind in his
labs and petri dishes with bacterial
cultures and when he came back one of
them had developed a mold which killed
the bacteria
and well the rest as they say is history
well maybe not just yet as we're about
to discover the real story was a lot
longer and a lot more complicated and
definitely involved a lot more people
history might have preferred to condense
it down to one manageable
bite-sized chunk but today we're going
to look
at the full course meal
[Music]
alexander fleming came from humble
beginnings he was born on august 6
1881 at lockfield farm near the small
town of darville
in ayrshire scotland he was the seventh
of eight children of hugh fleming with
the last four coming from his second
marriage to grace sterling morton
fleming's father was a farmer his mother
came from a farming family
he grew up on a large remote 800 acre
farm that was a mile away from the
nearest house
he and his siblings spent their earliest
years roaming through the nearby valleys
streams and moors
ensuring that the future man of science
would always have a fondness and respect
for nature the family suffered a major
setback in 1888 when hugh fleming
passed away his eldest son from that
first marriage took over the day-to-day
operations of the farm
as for alexander fleming or alec as the
rest of the family had called him he
began his education at ludenmoor
school a small place that only had a
dozen or so students of different ages
who were all taught
in the same classroom from there he
moved to darval school which was a bit
more advanced but required young alec
to walk eight miles every single day it
didn't take long for other people to
recognize fleming's academic potential
and at age 11 he was awarded a
scholarship to killmon knock academy a
state-funded secondary school and only
one of two schools in the whole united
kingdom the other being the prestigious
eaton college
which has educated two nobel prize
laureates fleming spent two years
at this academy but when he was 13 he
got the opportunity to continue his
studies in london
one of his older brothers tom had moved
to the city to study medicine and
later opened a practice there soon
enough four of his younger siblings alec
included joined him and
lived together in london fleming
enrolled in the royal polytechnic
institution where again
he impressed with his book learning and
acumen he was skipped ahead two years
and
finished school when he was just 16.
from there he needed a job and found
work with a shipping office
he spent four years at that place but
later recalled that he did not enjoy the
experience
in 1900 alec found a much needed break
from the work he disliked by joining two
of his brothers in the second
boer war in south africa all part of a
volunteer infantry unit called the
london scottish regiment however they
never actually saw any action before the
war ended and
mostly spent their time honing their
shooting and swimming skills
by the time he returned to london a
stroke of good luck befell fleming
in 1901 when he was 20 years old he
received an inheritance of roughly 250
pounds from his uncle john fleming
it wasn't a vast fortune or anything but
it was enough for him to quit his
nine-to-five job and continue his
studies
at the encouragement of his older
brother tom who now had a thriving
medical practice
fleming enrolled in med school there's a
myth which is still popular today which
states that fleming's education was paid
for by the churchill family because
fleming's father once saved winston
churchill from drowning as a boy
in gratitude winston's father lord
randolph churchill
promised to give young alexander the
same kind of education that his own son
would receive
the story continued decades later during
world war ii when churchill fell gravely
ill due to pneumonia
but his life was saved once again by a
fleming
thanks to the penicillin developed by
alexander this is
quite a fanciful tale and it most likely
still persists today because
it involves two popular larger-than-life
figures of their time
unfortunately though there is no
evidence to back it up and fleming
himself dismissed this as
nothing but a wondrous fable there is
nothing on the churchill side to lend it
credence either and
as you might suspect the life of the
prime minister has been
extensively documented the simple truth
is that fleming obtained an inheritance
and because he had
excellent scores in his examinations he
could more or less have his pick of
colleges
he chose to mary's hospital medical
school in paddington because it was
close to his home and
because he once played water polo
against their team in 1906 he
graduated from the school with
distinction and began his career in
medical research
this was not his original choice and in
fact he made it through a strange set of
circumstances
at first fleming intended to become a
surgeon as it happened due to his time
in the boer war
alec was quite a skilled marksman and
one of the top
shooters on saint mary's rifle club team
he was so valued in fact that the club
captain did not want him to leave which
is what would have happened if fleming
had become a surgeon instead he
convinced the scotsman to pursue a
career in research and some mary's and
even got him a position working under
sir elmira wright
that way everybody was happy the rifle
club kept one of its top sharp shooters
while fleming got to study under one of
the world's leading immunologists
[Music]
here fleming was exposed to wright's
ideas on vaccine therapies
which undoubtedly influenced his career
in 1908 he graduated with a bachelor of
science degree in bacteriology and
became a lecturer at
mary's a few years later fleming
developed a reputation as the go-to guy
in london if you were rich and had
syphilis
he began administering a new drug called
salvasan which today is known as
arsphenamine
it was created in the lab of german
physician and nobel prize laureate paul
ehrlich and
back then it was the first effective
treatment against syphilis
fleming was introduced to the drug by
wright and amassed a tidy sum of money
by being one of the main proponents of
salvasan in england
fleming's practice and his research
progressed along smoothly until world
war one broke out he enlisted and served
with the royal army medical corps as a
captain
during his time there he continued his
research into bacteriology in a
makeshift laboratory in bologna and
france
he saw many soldiers die due to infected
wounds and couldn't help but notice that
the antiseptics they were using
tended to make the injuries worse he
studied this problem
and wrote an article which was
subsequently published in the medical
journal the lancet in 1917. fleming
argued
that chemicals such as carbolic acid
which were used as antiseptic
were only efficient in certain cases
such as treating surface cuts
when dealing with deeper wounds the
chemicals did more harm than good as
they killed the body's own immunity
agents such as leukocytes and
also minimalized the body's ability to
protect itself from infections
according to his observations anaerobic
bacteria thrived in
deep wounds despite the presence of
antiseptics fleming a pines that in such
cases it was best to simply
leave the wound clean and let it dry and
then let nature take its course
his beliefs were echoed by his mentor
sir almath rye
who also argued that deep wounds should
only be cleaned using a simple saline
solution but
unfortunately their recommendations were
mostly ignored by
field doctors for the rest of the war
now just before we get into the rest of
today's video don't ignore
this recommendation it's the holidays
and we're all busy we've got plans to
arrange gifts to give places to go but
with today's sponsor brilliant you can
give the gift of learning i bet there's
someone you know who enjoys learning as
much as you do
and a subscription to brilliant could
make a perfect gift for them you've
heard me talk about brilliant before
maybe you even have a membership
yourself they teach you all about math
science and computer science but beyond
that they also teach you problem solving
skills which are practical
even if you don't pursue the sciences
learning how to break down complex
problems to their component parts is
pretty critical in whatever career path
you choose but look
really it's just a great way to take
what you learn on channels like this one
a step further or in this case you could
gift a premium subscription to someone
else so they can take
their knowledge further it's the gift of
learning and well
is there a better gift than that do it
right now at brilliant.org forward
biographics or click the link below
let's get back to it
even though fleming is renowned for his
discovery of penicillin he actually made
a different breakthrough
earlier in his career this one however
did not end up having a huge impact on
medicine so
it tends to get left behind after he
returned home from the war fleming
continued his studies into substances
with microbial properties and
he made an interesting discovery while
researching nasal mucus
the exact circumstances are somewhat
murky as there are different versions of
the story that have been repeated
some say he obtained the mucus sample
from a patient with a heavy cold
others say that fleming himself was
working while he had a cold and had
a eureka moment and decided to
investigate his own nasal drippings
further some also say that he simply got
lucky and a bit of snot dripped down
onto a petri dish when he was in the lab
regardless of how it got there fleming
wanted to see what effect the mucus
would have
on bacteria he mixed the two together
and let them sit for a few weeks when he
came back to investigate fleming
discovered that the nasal substance
completely killed the bacterial
colonies fleming realized that the
secretion must have contained an
antimicrobial component which was part
of the human body's innate immune system
it was an enzyme which fleming isolated
and named
lysozyme as he kept researching this new
substance he found that it was present
in
many other bodily secretions including
tears saliva
skin and hair subsequently the
bacteriologist discovered that lysozyme
was also present in egg whites which
meant that huge quantities could be
isolated with relative ease
this could have been a major boon for
the field of immunology but
unfortunately the enzyme was mostly
effective against harmless airborne
bacteria
rather than anything actually dangerous
today it's mostly used as a food and
wine preservative
even so it showed fleming the potential
in this kind of research and
set him on track to make a discovery
that would revolutionize medicine
forever
fleming once wrote when i woke up just
after dawn on september 28
1928 i certainly didn't plan to
revolutionize
all medicine by discovering the world's
first antibiotic
or bacteria killer but i suppose that
was exactly what i did
the scientist was looking for a better
alternative to lysozyme the latter
showed itself worthy as a proof of
concept but
surely there had to be another substance
out there somewhere
which was more effective against
dangerous bacteria to that end fleming
had begun experimenting and
studying the properties of a bacterium
called staphylococcus a
nasty piece of work that could cause
abscesses sore throats and boils
fortunately for fleming and the rest of
the world the bacteriologist was
not exactly a tidy man in august 1928 he
went on a family vacation with his first
wife a
nurse named sarah mcelroy in tow was
their four-year-old boy
robert he grouped up all of his petri
dishes which contained bacterial
colonies
and left them near an open window in his
lab in some versions of the story this
carelessness was ascribed to one of his
assistants
not to fleming himself when the doctor
returned on september the 3rd he
noticed that one dish had been
contaminated with mold spores this
annoyed him at first but
then he saw that there were no bacterial
colonies near the mold
the latter had killed all of the
bacteria that it came into contact with
and inhibited its growth fleming
isolated the mold and identified it as a
rare strain of penicillin
note hartum he gave his new creation the
unfortunate name
of mold juice and it wasn't until
several months later that he decided
that
a rebranding might be in order and he
came up with penicillin
an appealing name aside fleming's mold
juice immediately showed great promises
it proved effective not only against
staphylococcus but other harmful
bacteria such as meningococcus
streptococcus and
the diphtheria bacillus the first
antibiotic had been created
and the world now had a potential cure
for pneumonia gonorrhea meningitis
scarlet fever and
other infectious diseases well actually
not so fast in reality the process of
taking penicillin and turning it from
simple mold into a practical medicine
was long and difficult
and involved a lot of work from many
different scientists
fleming's role is undeniable but to give
him sole credit for
ushering in the era of antibiotics is
doing a disservice to many other
brilliant minds
first off let's talk about his
precursors fleming was the first to
isolate and identify the bacteria
killing mold and
treat other people with it but the
phenomenon itself had been around for
millennia
ancient cultures like the egyptians were
noted for the practice of applying
pulses made from
moldy bread to wounds to prevent
infections in modern times an english
physician named sir john burden
sanderson
might have been the first to observe and
report that certain molds from the
penicillium family could
inhibit the growth of bacteria back in
1871. inspired by his work joseph lister
the father of antiseptic surgery
established a year later that penicillin
glaucum had the potential to kill off
bacteria
but never published his findings many
other scientists came before the
scottish doctor but for whatever reasons
they were never able to take their
own research to its conclusion even
fleming himself found it difficult at
first to make others care about his
discovery
in 1928 he isolated the mold he called
it penicillin and began treating people
with it
in june the following year fleming
published his findings in the british
journal of experimental pathology to
a very lukewarm and uninterested
reception back then people could
not yet see how antibiotics could change
the medical world and
this included fleming himself in the
article he made few mentions regarding
penicillin's potential medical
applications and
instead focused on how it could be used
in a mixed culture to separate
bacteria sensitive to the mold from
bacteria
that had no reaction to it he had two
assistants stuart craddock and frederick
ridley who were given the arduous task
of finding ways to isolate pure
penicillin
from the fungus which produced it
however the substance was
unstable and they were only able to
produce solutions of crude material
for a while it looked like manufacturing
large quantities of penicillin
would just be nigh impossible
[Music]
during the 1930s fleming continued his
research on penicillin but
never made that breakthrough that would
have turned it into the life-saving drug
that we know today the same problems
remained all throughout the decade the
penicillin was too impure
and could not be mass-produced that
breakthrough did happen
eventually but it came from a team at
oxford led by australian pharmacologist
howard florey
his group worked in a research
department named the sir william dunn
school of pathology
better known simply as the dunn school
they started their work on penicillin in
1939 with
the main goal being to isolate and
stabilize enough of it to be usable on
humans
besides flory some of the other key
members of the oxford team were german
biochemist ernst chain english biologist
norman heatley and english biochemist
edward abraham however their program
needed so much penicillin mold filtrate
for animal experiments and clinical
trials that soon enough
pretty much the entire dunn school
worked on the project so we could never
give full credit to everyone who played
a part in developing the life-saving
antibiotic
their efforts were also slowed down by
another minor issue called world war ii
so it wasn't likely they had
any abundance of manpower and resources
in fact to save on space and materials
they began growing bacteria cultures in
whatever vessels they had on hand like
bathtubs food tins and
even bedpans edward abraham correctly
deduced the structure of penicillin at
roughly the same time as american
chemist robert burns woodward
norman hartley suggested that larger
volumes of penicillin could be produced
by extracting it
into amyloacetate and then back into
water
chain and foley discovered how to
isolate and concentrate the germ-killing
agent found in penicillin
in 1940 the team used penicillin to
protect mice from streptococcus
a year later a policeman named albert
alexander became the first human to
receive the oxford penicillin in order
to treat a bad infection that he had
inside his mouth
although alexander made a quick recovery
in just a few days they didn't have
enough of the drug to deal with the
infection completely
and it returned in a few days and killed
him not an auspicious start but
subsequent patients fared better and
showed the world the value
of penicillin as medicine the challenge
of scaling up production of the drug to
industrial quantities was eventually
taken up by british
and american pharmaceutical companies
particularly the northern regional
research laboratory
nrrl in illinois a subsidiary of the
united states department of agriculture
as you can see there were many
individuals and institutions that played
a vital role in the development of
penicillin as an antibiotic
for their work they were awarded the
nobel prize in physiology or medicine in
1945 although it only recognized
alexander fleming howard florey and ernt
chain due to one of the foundation's
most controversial rules of awarding a
nobel prize
and that's that it must be a maximum of
three people named
fleming spent his entire professional
career as a researcher at saint mary's
and in 1946 he succeeded his mentor
amrith wright as
head of the hospital's inoculation
department which was renamed to
the wright fleming institute he also
served as president of the society for
general microbiology
director of edinburgh university a
member of the pontifical academy of
science and even as honorary tree for
the native american tribe
in addition to these fleming pretty much
received every other honorary medal and
doctorate under the sun
for his part fleming always made sure to
acknowledge the efforts of florey and
his team in
making penicillin a worldwide commodity
but the general public and the media
seemed
determined to lavish their praise solely
on the scottish microbiologist probably
because the story of his happy accident
was just more enjoyable
in his later years fleming concentrated
his efforts on warning people about a
problem that we face right now
and that's resistance to antibiotics
both he and aleth wright realized early
on that microbes could very easily
become resistant to penicillin
if the wrong doses were used or for too
short a period
each subsequent generation of
microorganisms was also more resistant
than the last
he wrote several papers on the matter
and even mentioned it during his speech
for the nobel prize
in his private life fleming was quiet
and unassuming his son robert followed
in his father's footsteps
studying medicine and becoming a general
practitioner his first wife sarah passed
away in 1949 and
unsurprisingly this had a profound
effect on fleming who
buried himself in his work and spent a
lot of time alone in his laboratory
until the late hours of the night
fleming's life brightened up
considerably when he met dr
amelia coltsori varejkas who came to
work at some mary's the two fell in love
and married in 1953 but that happiness
was short-lived
alexander fleming died suddenly two
years later on march the 11th 1955
of coronary thrombosis he had been
feeling poorly over the last few weeks
but was convinced that it was only
gastric distress
when he started feeling nauseous on the
day of his death his wife wanted to call
a doctor but he insisted
that that wasn't necessary he had a
heart attack minutes later and was
subsequently buried at some paul's
cathedral
alexander fleming's life may have been
extinguished in a matter of moments but
he left behind
a life-saving legacy that will live on
forever one that few people
in history could ever hope to match so i
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do
give us a like below and don't forget to
subscribe also please do check out our
fantastic sponsor brilliant they are
linked to below
and as always thank you for watching